rostov en russie la hausse ont évacué
les habitants du dombass notre
correspondante malice d'estrées
justement sur place le point avec elle
sur la situation
nous trouvons actuellement devant le
sanatorium biais zahar aujogue près de
la frontière avec la république
autoproclamée de dounia sq et de
lougansk depuis cette nuit femmes
enfants personnes âgées ou handicapées
franchissent la frontière et arrive dans
la région de rostov sur le don face à
cet afflux de réfugiés un état d'urgence
local a été décrété selon les derniers
chiffes près de 1700 civils dont
quelques 700 enfants ont sont arrivés en
autobus et ont trouvé refuge dans des
centres d'hébergement provisoires tels
que celui ci vis ont nourri et une aide
médicale aurait apporté le cas échéant
je vous propose d'écouter des
témoignages de femmes évacués du donbass
qui ont trouvé refuge ici les conditions
d'accueil sont excellentes tout nous
plaît tellement ici que nous ne
voudrions plus partir ensuite
notre chef denis pucci l'hymne de la
république populaire autoproclamé de
donetsk a déclaré que tout devait être
organisé qu'il fallait prévoir des bus
pour évacuer les gens et nous nous
sommes préparés rapidement en courant
bien sûr nous avons oublié certaines
choses et c'est tout on est là on nous a
préparé un dîner où
un grand nombre de civils du donbass
arrive également par leurs propres
moyens en voiture et sont hébergés chez
des proches d'après le gouverneur de la
région rostov peut actuellement
accueillir 13 mille réfugiés une
capacité qu'il prévoit de porter à vingt
mille personnes selon un décret de
vladimir poutine chaque réfugié recevra
dès ce samedi 10 mai roubles soit
environ 115 euros pour couvrir ses
dépenses essentielles compte tenu de la
situation épidémiologique toujours tendu
plus de 2 millions d'autotest qu'ovide
seront fournis dans les centres
d'hébergement provisoire indique le
ministre régional de la santé face au
nombre croissant de réfugiés qui
arriveront ces prochaines heures une
vingtaine d'autres régions russes ont
d'ores et déjà annoncé qu'elle était
prête à les accueillir